there's this clown uh jimmy kimmel you
guys all know this jimmy kimmel guy and
the only reason i even bring up this
clip is because he's talking about the
durham story and unfortunately because
our media is so dead brain dead and just
awful plenty of people seemingly get
their news from these late night hosts
not that their ratings are so great but
people do watch them for news because
they have all become activists like they
do politics all night long so here's
what jimmy kimmel has
has to say about the durham story
meanwhile trump's terrible kids are
making the rounds
desperately trying to protect the golden
goose last night eric took time out of
his busy schedule to promote this
made-up hillary clinton spying case
they're now pumping into the fox news
viewers soft oatmeal like brain
the fox news viewers soft oatmeal like
brains i mean he's saying that to his
audience who i'm fairly certain at all
i'm going to say the r word they've told
me not to say the r word they're they're
not bright people that are watching
jimmy kimmel uh jimmy kimmel is also a
big blackface enthusiast there's jimmy
kimmel in blackface there he is
pretending he's carl malone yeah and he
talks in third person and makes fun of
the way that carl malone talks and it's
not just jimmy kimmel in blackface
there's his ex-girlfriend there's sarah
silverman in blackface that's weird
being a blackface guy and dating a
blackface girl and you know mocking
other people for having soft oatmeal
like brains you obvious racist person
you must be by your own rules you're an
evil racist and and should be banned and
censored and all of those things right
that's how we play this game uh but not
making about jimmy kimmel's blackface um
you know he goes after trump's kids
there i just want to say you know i
become pretty good friends with don jr
specifically he is a good guy he is a
good family man he loves his kids um he
is a decent guy fighting for what he
believes and i i just have no doubt that
he's a better person than jimmy kimmel i
just have no doubt like it's not even
close um i i know eric a tiny bit i met
ivanka once like they they are basically
good people okay i can't sit here and
tell you i know every little thing about
them but just the way he dismisses them
you know it's funny like
they're not crack addicts joe biden has
a crack addict son if you want to talk
about presidents and former presidents
and their children i don't necessarily
blame joe biden for his crack addict's
son but you know we're not allowed to
talk about that right like when that
story was breaking during the election
that's when new york post got banned
from twitter and we if you posted the
story anywhere you were going to get
banned from facebook and everywhere else
so uh i don't like jimmy kimmel very
much not a good guy not a fan of the
jimmy kimmel